it is a thursday morning 6 45 time to
see what's trending and look who it is
it's las vegas now host mercedes
martinez joining us live now from the
mix 94.1 studio mercedes good morning
good morning you two first up here's
what's trending as if fans aren't
already heartbroken enough over the
breakup of camila cabello and shawn
mendes sean has just released a new song
called oh it'll be okay take a listen
[Music]
the breakup ballad dropped exactly two
weeks after the couple split and for
what it's worth when he posted that the
song was out camilla cabello liked the
post okay next up something not so sad
the house from home alone is hitting
airbnb
you can stay where the mcallister's
lived in the movie on december 12th for
just 25 bucks it's gonna be decorated
for the holidays complete with booby
traps junk food chicago's finest pizza
and a real life tarantula no thank you
you can start booking it on tuesday but
this follows the release of home sweet
home alone on disney plus john heather
you know the homework house is an
amazing house it really is placed in
chicago there i love that good good
price i hate that
all right mercedes the golden girls
that show ended nearly three decades ago
but people still can't get enough of the
ladies down in florida and just as much
as they did today and from back then i
love planche so they're creating
something like comic con what's up with
that
yeah instead of comic con it's called
golden con thank you for being a fan
it's being held in chicago in april and
fans are all gathering to celebrate
friendships scandinavian nitwits sexy
southern belles stern substitute
teachers and sicilians i'm guessing
there'll be a little cheesecake that
they can enjoy there too john nether
all of the classic moments oh gosh that
was just it was a great show i can't get
over it i think we all identify with one
of them do you is there one that you are
like that's my person i like blanche i
think she's so funny which one was she
was she the sexy southern belle that's
what i thought okay yes yeah yeah i
think people would think that about me
too
a sexy southern belle
you are you are yeah let's let's not
pursue that anymore but they do have an
ugly christmas sweater so we can get
that for john yeah just in case mercedes
thank you very much we'll catch up with
you
later on this week bye mercedes
something like